[Music]
an astounding 112 of Aretha's songs hit
the charts into her they were all like
family they're like your children you
love them all but one song in particular
respect became her signature something
that we all need something that you got
to have it respect we were with her in
1997 when she recorded an update of the
song
I didn't think over a long period of
time it would still stand the test of
time the way that it has
[Music]
respect was written and recorded by R&B
legend Otis Redding originally but when
Aretha recorded it she added this famous
refrain around Detroit there was a
cliche sockitumi Nathan came along took
soccer to me and never gave me a dime
[Music]
Franklin covered lots of classics over
the years like a natural woman and
bridge over troubled water I just like
the song it's great say a little prayer
Dionne Warwick recorded prior to my
recording it and I thank her for
bringing that to my attention but some
of her biggest hits
Aretha wrote herself since you've been
gone I wrote millions on neck
think I wrote million-selling record the
basis of him soul and soul is absolutely
enduring
[Applause]
[Music]
she really was one of the time yeah and
she will be missed now a source confirms
to ET that one of her readers closest
friends Clive Davis is planning a
tribute concert that will take place on
November 14th at Madison Square Garden
we're told it was in the works before
arenas health took a turn for the worst
I bet you it will be a spectacular night
oh you don't know a lot of big-name show
her the respect that yes
[Music]